yeah for everything because basically we
exchange stuff and
thank god i didn't and you i have
everything
how i was conditioned to with that story
well i didn't remember her story but
she said when she said remember and i go
uh-huh and then she goes no that was
before and then i went uh-huh
so now i'm conditioned to just do [ __ ]
when
i'm lying i'm lying wow yeah because i
want to get in trouble
i want to i want i want to pretend that
i remember everything all of our moments
interesting i only
i remember seven things maybe well let's
play two truths and a lie
okay so you're gonna say two truths and
one lie and bobby has decided which one
is the lie
because he doesn't even know anymore
okay you do the same yeah and you
have two truths and a lie for her two
truths and a lie and one lie
okay so naked clown i have to make it
all right i don't know we're first three
i've never played this game before but
okay
okay my first three my grandmother's
name
is ramona okay that's
um
i've i've eaten out
three [ __ ] in my life that's two two
okay
the fun one yeah and um
[Laughter]
third one second um i'm trying to think
of like facts for a listening baby
don't make you got two keep it fast yeah
yeah yeah um
and then my um best friend's name
growing
up was um theresa may
okay so just recapped all right so
ramona is the mama grandmother
theresa may and three [ __ ]
yeah so the lie is this theresa may
yeah wow he remembered no i don't
remember but let me just not
don't [ __ ] tell you show us your
logic out of all
my experiences with her right i have
never heard of theresa may
out of nowhere theresa may yeah yeah
your best friend
best friend in high school theresa may
is a prime minister of england for
starters
so you should know that's a lie can i
just say this you [ __ ]
idiot all right i'm pretty sure there's
more than one truce amazing on planet
earth yeah
okay you also took a long time yeah yeah
yeah
you never wait till the last one i don't
know how to play this game okay
now bob's gonna try to stump you okay
okay two truths and a lie right
um all right here we go my
um my grandmother and her side of the
family
are part of the royal family of korea
okay number two
my dad used to work at the ups
and number three um my brother
um had an infection in his mouth
where he had a headache like surgical
not surgically but they had to put it
like a mouth thing
to close it up so he couldn't open his
mouth interesting there's some tricks in
here i can't tell
at what age he was 16. no follow-up
questions
okay no follow-up questions so break
down those three yeah use your logic
what do you know but for a month you had
to have it in though ooh he keeps adding
information um
his dad never worked ups uh-huh okay
good so
what's the lie that's a lie no my dad
you work for the ups
[Applause]
he had three jobs he worked at ups he
was like working for like some ice cream
[ __ ] company or whatever delivering
[ __ ] and he worked for the male
he had like your brother never had a
mouth infection no
i feel like your brother i've taken your
brother to the dentist for a mouth
infection
let me just say something right now who
won that game king did i did you know
why
because i'm the deceiver because they
were all lies
i'm the king of all deceptions i'm the
shadow of all shadows
you cannot see within me i'm hearing i'm
not i'm between the edges
all right i'm beneath i'm above i'm not
around
but i'm here happy halloween happy
halloween
can i just say something else my dad did
work for the ups
what is real that's what it is that's
what life is
no what's that yes life is deception
life is shadow play
and and now you no one knows what the
truth is what is it i'm going to tell
you because i'm a wizard
i'm going to find out from you oh yeah
yeah did your dad work for the ups
all right i'm going to call him actually
yeah call him right now live
okay
but anyway um my brother did not have an
infection his mother in fact you didn't
know i was lying because i was making up
like
like mouth he had a head shot with the
device you know i mean that could have
gave it away no
you kept lying but then you would add a
little i know that's only to can like
you know strengthen the line with
adhesives
like all that stuff yeah closer closer
speaker
hey um did your dad ever work for the
ups
yeah he did um a long time ago
yeah he did yeah when he first
he was there i remember him telling me
he used to um
because he was so small he used to like
load the
trucks like on his ass and he like got a
bunch of boxes in that way
yeah the wrong time he had an ass system
all right okay thanks steve thank you
canada confirmed we thought your brother
was lying no
no he did he actually did yeah thank you
okay thank you i love you
thank you see you [ __ ] [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] are you trying to do the ass
system
the assistant whatever it is you don't
know what the ass has to be what is the
ass system
he used to like i don't know like
because he did he is so small i guess he
used to scoot
i don't know what the system was but i
don't know but my point is is this is
that my dad used to work for the eps and
i win
wow deception okay it's just complete
deception there's no theresa may
there is no teresa may as a friend are
you you said that you wouldn't lost that
game
no i'm i i feel good about not being the
better liar
oh i'm a really good liar he is he can
look you
dead in the eye yeah and tell you i
did not do that